[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what's going on everybody welcome to the
bridge size Cipher thank you all for
joining us on a beautiful Wednesday
afternoon the bridge side Cipher we are
a non-profit organization based in
Cambridge and uh we're really excited to
come to MIT you know and kind of build a
bridge between our community the hip-hop
community and MIT I actually grew up in
Cambridge and my father was a professor
at MIT for over 40 years he's sitting
right there Jonathan can't give it up
still has an office in the biology
Department right over there this used to
be a parking lot I used to come and park
here so we'd go to the clinic to see my
pediatrician right here and it was a
trashy parking lot
um and now it's just this beautiful
space and it's so great to have us have
an opportunity to come and perform here
and create a space for hip-hop and for r
b yo I had this first crush yo
Kindergarten now we're training them up
because I used to leave Valentine's in
this cubby I came home crying when he
said he didn't love me yeah and then my
high school student
[Music]
but that's what he prefer so I decided
that he wasn't for me
[Music]
so bougie after mad sick he wasn't even
that so cheap
[Music]
talk to me
foreign
[Music]
I remember the first time that you told
me you loved me I ain't feel judged you
must be in your eyes
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
how do you like what you've done for me
I can't really explain it
[Music]